PROFESSOR: We ask,
is psi of x, 0 real?
And I told you the answer is no.
And how would I know
that this is not real?
Well, we can take the
complex conjugate.
And at the end of the
day, this will boil down
to some property of phi of k.
You see, you have an expression
phi of x in terms of phi of k.
So it would not be surprising
that the requirement
that psi is real means
something about phi of k.
So let's just say, suppose
psi is given by that,
then psi x, 0 star,
the complex conjugate
would be 1 over square root
of 2 pi integral phi of k star
e to the minus ikx dk.
I conjugated everything in that
equation for psi of x and 0.
Now, you want to compare
this with psi of x and 0
to see if it's real.
Or let's consider what is the
condition that this be real.
So I want to simplify
here a little more.
So what I'm going to do is
going to change variables,
by changing k to minus k.
If you prefer to go
a little more slowly,
you could say you're
going to change k prime--
you're going to be a
new k, called k prime,
equals to minus k.
But it's possible
to do it this way.
Now, there's going to
be a couple of changes.
Wherever you see k, you're
now going to see minus k--
so 1 over 2 pi integral
phi of minus k.
And I'll just put this star
here, not so many parentheses--
e to the minus ikx becomes ikx.
And the dk will go to minus dk,
but the order of integration,
that was from minus infinity
to plus infinity, would switch.
So those two signs cancel.
So there's a sign from
doing dk to minus dk,
and 1 from the limit
of integration--
so at the end of the
day, you have dk,
and you still have this--
minus infinity to infinity.
And you can say, well,
is this equal to--
or what is the condition
of for psi to be real?
Well, is this equal to 1
over 2 pi minus phi of k, e
to the ikx dk--
is that-- question mark--
is that equal to it?
That would mean
that the psi of x, 0
is real, because this thing
is just psi of x and 0.
So this is a question
mark-- this is a condition.
So here you could say, exploring
the reality condition--
condition-- when
is a psi of x real?
So what must be true
is that these two terms
must equal each other.
So, in fact, this requires--
reality requires that 1 over
square root of 2 pi integral
from minus infinity
to infinity phi of k
minus phi star of minus k, e
to the ikx dx is equal to 0.
I brought the two
terms to one side.
Both are of the same type--
they're integrated
against an e to the ikx.
And therefore, we
can combine them,
and that's what must be true
in order for the function
to be real.
And now you can
say, so what is it?
What's the answer?
Well, this integral
should vanish.
Now, this integral
should vanish--
it should vanish
for all values of k.
So actually, what
you want to conclude
is that this thing
is identically 0.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, shouldn't
that be dk and not dx?
PROFESSOR: Yes, thank you.
Thanks very much.
So this property that this whole
integral be equal to 0, you
were tempted to
conclude that it means
that this thing is equal to 0.
And that is correct--
that is a perfectly
legal argument.
And it basically-- if you want
to express it more precisely,
you could base it on the
Fourier theorem, again.
These two sets of equalities
here are Fourier's theorem.
And look what this is saying--
this is saying that this
quantity has a 0 Fourier
transform.
Because how do you do
the Fourier transform
of a function of k?
You multiply by e to
the ikx and integrate.
And therefore, this function
has a 0 Fourier transform.
So, but if a function has
a 0 Fourier transform,
the function must be 0.
Because already this is
0, and the integral is 0--
0.
So this is absolutely rigorous.
And therefore, you
get the conclusion
that phi of minus k star
must be equal to phi of k,
and that's the
condition for reality.
So if a phi of k satisfies
this property, that psi of x
will be real, and our phi of k
doesn't satisfy this property,
what do you see
in this property?
Basically, if you have phi that
exists for some value of k,
it should also exist for
the value of minus k.
And in fact, should be
the complex conjugate
of the other value.
But here, you have some phis
of k, and no phis at minus k.
So the phi that we wrote above
doesn't satisfy this condition.
And therefore psi is not
real, and it all makes sense.
OK, so basically,
if you were plotting
not the absolute value,
but the real part
and the imaginary
parts of psi, you
would see some sort
of funny waves.
I think if you were plotting
the real part, for example,
you would see a wave like that.
And if you were plotting
the imaginary part,
you'd presumably see some
other wave like that.
And the absolute value,
it's much nicer and simpler.